welcome to your round six recap of the  sink filled cup the strongest chess  tournament in history well it's Joe  DiMaggio's 56-game hitting streak the  Miami Dolphins perfect season in 72 and  now it's fabulous fabiano caruana with a  60 no score blitzing the field in an  epic performance one of the greatest in  chess history he demolishes opponent  today veselin topalov with a vicious  King side attack and after this move  Bishop takes rook his opponent had to  resign fabiano showing his style like no  one has seen in over 20 years I just  want to play so solidly the remaining  games just keep playing normal chance  with four rounds to go karana has a  chance to etch his name in the history  books forever be sure to join us for  live coverage of the same field cup here  in st. Louis at 150 central at us chess  champs calm